nobody tell us about an occurrence that
sufficiently gzd okay thank you very
much pleasure to be here and speak again
four years later so actually four years
ago and there was a the previous
semester I gave gave a talk about
chronicle coefficients on their own like
in combinatorics knowing that they have
some relevance to GCT but back then I
didn't really know exactly what the
relevance is and what how can they help
but now thanks to thanks to that
involvement now we we actually have some
some better understanding and so let me
tell you what happens since for the past
four years but because I doubt that
anyone may some of you were here four
years ago but you probably don't
remember so let me give you some basics
from algebraic combinatorics which is my
field and in my perspective on these
problems so some of the the basic
subjects income in algebraic
combinatorics these permutations and
integer partitions the symmetry group s
and will be featured quite well widely
and the general linear group as well and
these are things that you've already
seen in previous talks the young diagram
of a partition is just an arrangement of
boxes and for us it's going to be sort
of important because that's a nice way
to encode highest weight vectors and to
visualize and represent a herb some
things we know about representation
theory okay so this is very basic and so
already Peter already talked about this
but let me take a step back so what our
group representation
for example in the case of the symmetry
group but in in for any type of group
these are ways to encode the group
elements as matrices which obey the same
group laws so the matrices are quite
universal objects and for example here
is such a very it's a very standard to
actually the permutation representation
for for the permutation group SN where
it elements the permutations are
represented by their permutation
matrices so we will all since in this
this is an example of secure
presentation and the point is that these
representations can be concern becomes
into irreducible so what does
irreducible mean that these are this
would be ways to truth through the bases
for for for these representations such
that when we the change into this basis
the matrices will become block diagonal
and the minimal such decomposition so
the smallest possible blocks we can
decompose and this would be the
reducible components and so for example
in this representation there are two
irreducible components these are the
vector spaces spanned by the sum of the
basis vector this is so this would like
one dimensional representation the
trivial one and then this is the next
the next interesting representation
actually the thing the sign
representation here which would basis
this vector and in general we know we
have we have classified the reducible
representations of the symmetric group
and these are the spec modules they
correspond to integer partitions all the
partitions of lambda
and for example in this case we have a
stray it turns out that v1 corresponds
to the Spade module with one rope
integer partition and v2 is this other
this this other representation which
would correspond to the partition to one
and in the combinatorial way of thinking
about this speck modules is via this
object standard and Thabo when we assign
the numbers from 1 up to n to this boxes
also that each number appears exactly
once and they're increasing along rows
and down columns and these these are
indexing a basis of Salama in some sense
but the operations are quite complicated
so it's not it's not so easy to describe
what the representation actually is even
on this object and for for what we will
need later is of course the general
linear group and they're the reducible
representations are also indexed by
partitions lambda there are the vile
modules and this time however the size
of the partitions can be anything except
that the number of parts is limited by
the size of the general linear group and
one tool that may that would be
underlined may be some of the results
you will see later in a way to study
representations and in particular
multiplicities of irreducible
representations are the short functions
because they actually they they their
basis for the ring of symmetric
functions and they correspond one-to-one
to this irreducible presentation the
viol module so if if we you can
manipulate the shoe functions one can
figure out exactly exactly in principle
what the representations are and they
have some two types of formulas like one
of them is this ratio of earn their
money ins
other one is the combinatorial
description in terms of semi standard
Yenta block so these are again feelings
of these diagrams called the
corresponding to this partitions with
the numbers from 1 up to whatever the
number of variables is here it said now
the rule is that they have to be weakly
increasing along rows and strictly
increasing down columns okay so you can
look up on YouTube how to you so from
four years ago I was explaining how to
use this these short functions to figure
out multiplicity synchronic it like
Kronecker coefficients and so on so we
are not gonna do this now and so now we
will get to like the actual results but
before it I need to define this is the
corresponding multi place it is so
natural thing to do is when you have two
irreducible presentation take the tensor
product of these representations is also
a representation of the corresponding
group and hence it can be decomposed
into irreducible and irreducible 's will
come into a certificates we group the
adipic components all together and the
number of times each other typic
component shows up is going to be the
multiplicity of this component into this
representation and in particular if we
take two irreducible gln representations
with answer them and the multiplicities
of the reducible are the so-called
little Richardson coefficients which
actually have a nice combinatorial
description and in computer science it
in terms it means that that calculating
the computing the little would
Richardson coefficient is in sharp P and
in fact
it turns out that deciding whether
they're positive or not is in P but this
is this is a an accident in some cells
and when we take a symmetric group
repair the symmetry group
representations spec modules we can
decompose under the diagonal action
again and these are these Chronicle
coefficients which were featured in the
title and for example you can do this by
hand one can take this these two spec
modules it turns out that they decompose
in this way to reducible so the
corresponding chronicle coefficients are
all ones for these two partitions and
any of the other ones and thanks to
shoreville duality the Kronecker
coefficients also show up in the in geo
representations and this is how they
will enter the business with permanent
weight and the plate ISM coefficients
correspond to compositions of
representations in general they can be
defined this way so again we are
factoring into reducible and these are
the multiplicities of irreducible but
for our purposes we're only gonna need
these plate isms coefficients like the
simplest possible compositions of
representation so the simple symmetric
powers
okay so the big problem was to figure
out the positive combinatorial
interpretation for the general linear
for the Kronecker coefficients and or to
even show that their computation is in
sharpie so far we only know that it's in
gap P originally the motivation was that
the crow the Littlewood richardson
coefficient show up as subset as a
special case of the Kronecker
coefficient and so one would of the
floor of the little wood richardson
coefficients and so so that that would
pose the natural problem that these are
non-negative integers we need to figure
out what they what they really counts in
a discrete way or just compute them in
sharply and modern motivation is what we
are interested in today is their their
role in geometric complexity theory and
also the Kronecker coefficients show up
in invariant theory in the study of
moment polytopes so this is one of the
particular problems of interest and
there has been a lot of work along those
lines it to you you you will see more of
later so what do we know about the
Kronecker coefficient so far basically
nothing so we only know some very very
special cases then when we have some
formulas and so only when like one
partition is a very long folk has a very
long first role and there's just two
rows with first row very alone or is is
a hook and there are some other special
cases that there are that level of
parameterization and we know some some
lower bound so in principle Kronecker
coefficients can be really large they
they can
be exponent so they can grow
exponentially but we still don't have
any criteria for their zero or not for
example and here are the consume of the
complexity results so in figuring out
whether a Kronecker coefficient is
positive is already an np-hard problem
is
okay so how do they what is their role
in the geometric complexity theory which
is what you already saw a little bit
from yesterday and Peter's talk so of
course the big problem is to separate VP
from vnp the determinant is the
universal VP polynomial there is a
notion of determinants of complexity
which you already know so here is an
example this polynomial can be evaluated
as a determinant with yes Littlewood
Richardson coefficients which are a
special case of Kronecker but in general
the Kronecker coefficients are a lot
more complicated so any other questions
okay so so here so we are looking so the
determinant of complexity this is going
to be just the size of the smallest
determinant which can compute a value a
tower our polynomial such that the
entries are a fine fine linear entries
in the variables and in this case with
what this polynomial can be evaluated
with a 2-byte the determinant of a 2 by
2 matrix or determinants of complexities
and the relation to VP is that
polynomial is in V P if and only if the
determinant of complexity is polynomial
in in the number of variables and the
degree of the polynomial and then there
is the permanent the permanent is the
universal B&P polynomial they're very
similar to the determinant of course and
that to show that VP is not equal to VN
the one can show that is equivalent to
showing that the determinant of
complexity of the permanent grows super
polynomial in M okay so now this makes a
problem algebraic in the sense that we
want to show that we cannot write the M
by M permanent as as the determinant of
an N by n matrix for any and that is
polynomial in M and so what we know so
far so Peter all already showed is that
the determinants of complexity of the
permanent is actually at most 2 2 to the
M so it's already exponential the
best-known lower bound is M squared over
2 so of course there is a big gap here
here is a formula which gives
determinants of complexity about M to M
times 2 to the M for the permanent and
this is what we know and now how do we
make the total G break version of the
problem and geometric complexity theory
how was to study the orbits of the
determinants under the action of GL and
square that because again so we are
replacing the entries by a fine linear
combination so it's natural to take the
action of the general linear group and
so we have the determinant of polynomial
GL and acts on the variables in this in
this form and we are looking at the
orbit so all possible polynomials we can
get in this way but these are so these
are invertible matrices in principle
that these entries might not be
invertible so we need to take the orbit
closure and also we need we for the
algebraic geometry we will need this
variety and
and here is the permanent so we need to
homogenize it in this case to get the
the degrees of the polynomials to match
so will homogenize it with some one
extra variable or could be the same it
doesn't really matter and of course if
the permanent is not in the orbit
closure of this M by n determinant it
means immediately that the determinant
of complexity of the permanent is bigger
than and so this is the paradigm of G
cities to exploit this to get a lower
bound for the complexity of the
permanent and here is the the the P
versus V n P version from from G cities
that the permanent does not belong is
not in the orbit closure of the
determinant for any polynomial sized end
and so when permanent permanent being
endure the closure of the determinant we
can actually close take this the orbit
of the permanent as well and compared to
orbit closures okay so here is the
reformulation again and now we use this
representation theory that that we
already discussed is to to consider the
GL n squared the the gon squared action
on this on these varieties and take the
coordinate coordinate rings on this
these two varieties decompose them into
irreducible both and compare them and
see if we can find some lambda some
partition lambda such that the
multiplicity in one is bigger than the
multiplicity in the other which will
immediately show that the second one
cannot cannot cannot contain the first
one so
so this is the representation to your
attic or multiplicity obstruction is
when when the multiplicity of an
irreducible representation in the
coordinate ring of the orbit closure of
the determinant is smaller than the
multiplicity of their usable present a
the corresponding irreducible
representation in the calendar
coordinate ring of the orbit closure of
the permanent having count and so if if
this holds then immediately we have an
immediate consequence that this the
orbit closure the permanent cannot be in
something at least in one in one
irreducible this is bigger so their
containment cannot this containment
cannot happen so so then this will this
existence of one that will show that the
determinants of complexity of the
permanent is bigger than n okay so so we
need to compare this Delta and gamma
that we actually don't know what they
are so here is the conditioner
conjectures again and the smother is we
don't really have a good handle on these
multiplicities one hope was that there
would be such that are currents
obstructions when Delta when we consider
representations which do not show up at
all in the determinant but they show up
in the permanent this would obviously
separate both and and there was the the
weaker conjecture of GC t was that there
exists such occurrence obstructions
which we yesterday Peter told you the
punchline that it's wrong so this this
does not happen basically for any lambda
of interest this Delta M this is all
strictly positive and one way to get a
handle on this Delta and gamma is using
this Kronecker in
please and coefficients that just
mentioned since we don't really have a
good handle of what this exactly are and
but we know that so this so called
symmetric Kronecker this is actually the
multiplicity of lambda in the orbit of
the determinant so not the orbit closure
but it would be not per bound and the
symmetric chronic here is bounded above
by the normal chroniker coefficient for
two rectangular partitions and the plate
ISM coefficients just so these would be
the multiplicity of lambda in the ring
of all no in there in for the ring of
regular functioning on all polynomials
of degree n so this would be an upper
bound for four for the permanent in
particular bird for actually any such
padded polynomial and
and then there was a weaker conjecture
that so not knowing exactly what this
Delta is one can maybe hope that we get
the Kronecker coefficient to be zero
this would immediately imply that Delta
is also 0 and this will and if if this
lambda shows up in the coordinate ring
of the permanent that would lead to
except to the lower bound for the
determinants of complexity so this was
the pre pre pre conjecture and so before
we prove them no currents abstractions
with with Kristian we actually showed
that if n is already bigger than 3 m to
the fourth so so even so 4 for that for
that inequality between N and M
basically all interesting Kronecker
coefficients are already positive
already for for this or bound so we
cannot use this paradigm to separate
permanent from the terminal so this is a
stronger statement this one here or the
previous one are they so they are the no
occurrence obstructions hold cells maybe
show it in the next slide when n is
bigger than M to the 25th but this this
is too strong requirement because I mean
the real multiplicity is smaller than
the the chronic so so they are
remarkably just like so so morally they
they these the two statements overlap
but there is a little
discrepancies of when exactly they hold
and yeah you just cared about you know
can we get superpolynomial separations
then then you know correction yeah yeah
eyes this version yeah but this is
saying but this this is this is already
holding for my calf lower degree much
lower bound here also that is the
earlier statement okay so so here is
here so I here so the cry I'm trying to
give the talk in a more chronological
order so how things were developed also
to explain where the intuition came from
for the other for the other statement
that yes told you yesterday and he okay
so here is the other statement the other
statement says that if n is bigger than
M to the twenty-fifth then this Delta is
zero oh sorry sorry then the Delta is
not zero basically for for any partition
of interest
okay so I will so I will focus on this
statement because Peter already
explained how the other proof goes and
then I'll show what briefly mentioned
how the other one goes well and then
we'll move on to some other model that
can be studied with GCT and similar
multiplicities so how did we prove this
statement so so we need to know
something about the partitions of
interest what can occur in the core the
coordinate ring of the orbit closure of
the permanent the only thing we need to
know about the permanent is that it's
actually a padded polynomial so there is
this X to the N minus m showing up there
much larger degree which means that the
partitions which would show up here so
they are related to how the what the
monomials in the polynomial are they
need to have a very long first row so
first of all the length of the
partitions have to be at most M to the
squared because of the number of
variables involved and the body of the
partition so this is everything without
the first row has to be at most n times
D so this is the characterization we
really we really use an and nothing much
more than that
and
and the other characterization we need
is what what we call a degree degree
lower bound which I will explain a
little bit later get into inequality of
multiplicities but basically for at
least for this result we need to have
the degree which so there is an implicit
degree here has to be bigger than n then
n over m it is related to this bound
here as well and then we have to prove
what when are the Kronecker coefficients
positive and it turns out that four
partitions like that where we have a
very long first row already for this
type of bound we know that all Kronecker
coefficients of interest are both
positive so the Kronecker coefficient of
interest are lambda and then rectangle
rectangle and by determined by directing
so how do we prove anything about
Kronecker coefficients without really
having any type of formula for them and
yes
any homogeneous any palate homogeneous
polynomials yeah
there is dis Nizam does not use anything
specific about the permanent other than
its some polynomial in M Squared
variables degree M and then we are
padding by Anton by one variable and so
nothing else is used here which already
means that probably we should so that
any any any any method that should
separate the terminal from permanent
should should be a lot more specific
than that somehow so so okay so how do
we use the little we know about chronic
your coefficients and there is one thing
that is very crucial here is the so
called semi group property the semi
group property tells us that if we have
a triple of partitions maybe I can write
this down so so if we have some triple
of partitions let's say London Mew new
and from the prime mu prime nu prime
with positive Kronecker coefficients
then we can add them part wise and
we get this inequality in particular we
get another positive Kronecker koi fish
and there is one more property which
only calls for chronicle coefficients
and you can and this is text to the
symmetric group nothing and very very
particular is that we can actually
transpose so first of all we can switch
anything this this is symmetric in the
three partitions but we can also
transpose two of them and it is the same
chroniker coefficient it is obvious from
the from the from the symmetric group
but it's not obvious from any of the
general linear interpretations but so
one property follows from through Valdo
allottee with the general linear group
the other one follows from the symmetric
group and there is no unified view on on
both of this so it's makes it even more
interesting
okay so one so what what can what can we
do here well we know what to do at least
with one row this is the trivial
representation so we have some very
basic and yes what oh when chronicle
coefficients are positive and basically
this is allowing us to if we have some
partition with a positive chronic here
like here is a square and a square then
we can actually extend these two ends of
the partition and still get a positive
chronicle coefficient and this is thanks
to this combination of these two facts
that we can transpose add something
transpose again add something and so on
and so this is
this is how the pro goes and in this in
and then we have the Kronecker
coefficient for rectangle rectangle and
partition lambda with anything here
small enough that we can even calculate
is strictly positive okay so now we know
that our partitions have to have a very
long first row but maybe not too long
and we are we have these rectangles a
and B how do we get these coefficients
to be positive the point is again to use
this semigroup property and try to
decompose this partition into building
blocks which for which we already know
some positivity result and one should be
careful with decomposing rectangles
because the only way we can decompose a
rectangle is into two rectangles of the
same height so this so there is in
please inherently there are some number
theoretic issues of how we can just help
we can apply this semi group property
but with sufficient so we can we maybe
we can transpose the rectangles as well
so that's how we get varying lengths in
Heights of rectangles so here is how
that the composition goes so new is the
body of the partition so new is
everything except for the first row so
we split it into squares and call a
columns of width 2 and we use the
following positive it effects so first
of all this is so this is one not very
non-trivial result that the Kronecker
coefficient for three squares
positive and in fact for triple-triple
of particle symmetric partitions it
actually also true then we can do this
transpositions as I was just saying with
with this rectangle so that we can get
arbitrarily I mean in the end we have we
need to have this size of rectangle so
we need to match things right and then
we have the various hooks exceptional
cases and little partitions for whatever
would not fit into that type of the
composition of the partition and in the
end we go things together thanks to the
semi group property so this is these are
the ideas and how exactly we decompose
and all is this these are technical
details but basically this this the the
squares are ensuring that the lar large
chance of the partitions give positive
chroniker coefficients and the rest is
just to make sure we fill the gaps
correct
and so this degree lower bound that I
mentioned earlier it is it's an
interesting consequence because one can
actually show using complexity theory
that the chronic here is actually bigger
than the plate ISM so how does this work
let me just show you quickly so suppose
that the cross this Chronicle could so
first of all Chronicle coefficient
stabilize as well as plate ISM
coefficients when we grow the first the
first part of the partition and the
rectangles and one dimension on the
rectangles if these things grow
eventually they become constant both for
the partition for the chronicles and the
plate ISM so suppose where we are in the
stable range already then this
inequality holds so suppose it we have
things going the other way so the
Kronecker is smaller than this
let ISM then we can use this discourage
Landsberg result so so there is there is
a party is there is a particular lifting
that the multiplicity of this lambda in
the core did not drink here for
basically desire this is gonna be all
these private polynomials this is gonna
be greater than or equal to the smaller
plate ISM coefficient so this is only
particularly fitting we have this
stability result so this mu this is a
lambda when lambda grows beyond the
stability range so we already know we
are already there and the last thing is
GCT or in general the complexity theory
that's saying that if the multiplicity
of lambda here is bigger than the
Kronecker which is bigger than the
determinant multiplicity it means that
the terminal complexity this gives a
lower bound for the determinants of
complexity so there exist some
polynomial in this among among this
these ones here such that its
determinant of complexity is bigger than
n for one of these polynomials VM is
just off degree M polynomials in M
Squared variable so nothing particular
to the perman and then we get the
following so then the multiplicity here
is bigger is a bigger is already so
bigger than the Kronecker and but this
holds for every end because as we said
we already have and is in the stable
range which means that the determinant
of complexity for this polynomial is
bigger than n for any nine goes to
infinity which is impossible this is
already so it has to be it has to be
finite so this is what Peter explained
yesterday of how to know the stronger
stronger no currents obstruction result
calls but with a weaker bound in some
sense so he already gave the proof
yesterday the only thing he didn't
explain is how we exactly we were
constructing that we needed to show that
some plate ISM coefficients were
positive it it amounts to 10 so as a
contraction with specific the block
construction so that's a technical
aspect and the last five minutes I just
wanted to show you another model so when
we don't want to deal with this padding
which was obviously making things too
queasy well so we don't want to have to
deal with these lambdas with very long
first rolls so let's take this the power
of a matrix of a matrix X to the M so we
can talk about instead of determining
determinant replace this with the power
of a matrix there is a the power compose
Oh power complexity in some sense again
it's the smallest size matrix for which
we can compute our polynomial or in
particular the permanent in this fashion
and and it turns out that this PC and
the end the determinants of complexity
our polynomial equivalent so if you want
to separate VP from V and P we can look
at this PC instead and then the same
type of setup to look at the orbit
closure of the permanent versus the
orbit closure of the power of a matrix
and now there is no padding anymore okay
so what happens now
well so we we don't actually know what
happens in the orbit closure but we can
look at what happens in the orbit and
and/or the orbit the multiplicities of
the reducible can be used by calculating
the stabilizer and litter now they are
given by this formula this SK are the
symmetric chronicle coefficient so it's
actually a big sum here what turns out
that everything is positive already for
for a linear bound in this case all this
every every partition that could
possibly show up in here is already
positive so what are the restrictions
now we don't have this padding so the
only restriction that remains is just
from the number of variables involved at
the length of lambda is at most M
Squared and basically in all these cases
this this multiplicity here turns out to
be strictly positive so we cannot rule
out obstructions for discs with this
method
and the way it works the way the way we
prove this positivity so we we know even
less about the symmetric chronicle
coefficients we didn't even know how
they behaved for like column and row
partitions or something simple like that
but um this again we use semi group
property not for the chronic the
symmetric chronicles but for this entire
someone can use highest wave vectors to
show this semi group property for for
the total coefficient and then we need
to find something to find the row at
least to compute some symmetric
chronicle coefficients and one was with
when a partition is one column and then
there is an X so we can say exactly when
this is so this is going to be 1 or 0
and we can situation it again uses some
way of evaluating this with the block
constructions and we get this positivity
result and I will stop here with this
slide which has which which has a
conjecture and a formula to extend this
approach to the iterated matrix
multiplication and most time something
[Music]
I don't know if anyone away we haven't
so okay then maybe we should yeah maybe
maybe to busier to compute this
multiplicity so that there was no
padding so the only issue was so this
there is no padding here so did the
serum is specific to the permanent or it
also applies for any homogenous it also
applies for any Kumu genius polynomial
of degree M and M Squared variables you
should look very complicated and here
you have much more variables for it so
it's just that all the multiplicities
here are positive in them in the power
and and then then you need you need some
multiplicity abstraction or one also
needs to go to the to the closure which
we haven't done that another symbol
powers of in our form so wearing your
any digital care of course no bounds are
known using partial derivatives have you
tried
yes well it's so let me okay so actually
what
so Peter Peter explained this yesterday
so that we so there is a way to so so if
so that so basically the way we we prove
this result was actually to show that
the powers power sums appear in this
orbit closure of the determinant and and
basically what so what we show this that
we cannot actually worried the last
layer all right last one
what is the result for each rate
utilities multiplication
so this is the formula for the
multiplicity again it's this is not
closure this is so we cannot we cannot
do the we cannot do the multiplicity in
in the case of the core this is not that
this is not the quarter and the this
mode the multiplicity of lambda here is
equal to this big sum this small tile
veto would Richard some coefficients and
we have no idea how to characterize this
multiplicity is that you have for
disclosure ya know so let's stick all of
the discussions in the drink
[Applause]
[Music]